welcher idiot hat eigentlich behauptet
niedersachsen wäre langweilig das war
ich letzte woche ja dabei hat uns die
wahl da oben letzten sonntag eine
regelrechte sensation beschert die spd
lebt freunde sie lebt ja ja ist das so
die sozen holen in niedersachsen
unglaubliche 37 prozent so schade dass
sigmar gabriel das nicht mehr erleben
kann
ach nee kann ja wo ist der eigentlich
jetzt mal ehrlich niemand weiß es keiner
weise ja schulz hat wohl gesagt lasst es
wie einen unfall aussehen 37 prozent
holt stefan weil in hannover
dieser tausendsassa der hat so drauf der
typ dieser weil sogar schon früh morgens
um halb sechs typischerweise dann
schnappe ich mir ein bademantel gehen
mit geschlossenen augen zum briefkasten
holt mir die tageszeitung raus und den
rasierapparat es sieht man hier lesen
sie wirklich beim rasieren zeitung ja
doch das gibt's doch nicht rasieren und
lesen gleichzeitig ich habe gehört er
kann sogar beim bügeln aus dem fenster
gucken meine damen und ein wahnsinns typ
stephan weil wird in dieser woche in
mehreren deutschen leitmedien als
kommender spd kanzlerkandidat gehandelt
ja eher oder oder olaf scholz
ja
das habe ich leider nicht ausgemacht
mehrere seriöse zeitungen behaupten er
könnte der nächste kanzlerkandidat sein
dass fast das ganze elend dieser partei
schon zusammen ja sagte er unter den
einbeinigen ist der blinde könig oder so
ich nicht und ich fragen und derweil hat
der spd ihre würde zurückgegeben
bisschen dankbarkeit vielleicht mal
sie waren am boden
sie waren tote als elvis sie haben
längst bestimmten ihre organe waren
schon verkauft doch jetzt sind sie
wieder da
und warum wegen weil er ist einfach zu
weil für diese welt niedersachsen geht
weil wahlomat 3000 weil weil weil
einfach weil ist derweil weil es ganz
genau
und weil weil bewiesen hat wenn sich die
beiden großen volksparteien sowie in
niedersachsen gerade richtig beharken
dann schwächt das die fdp und die bürger
kriegen als strafe die nächste gruppe
aber in niedersachsen waren natürlich
vor allem wissen sie ein debakel für die
cdu da oben mit ihrem spitzenkandidaten
bernd althusmann ja norddeutschlands
bestes donald trump google wenn sie mich
fragen 12 prozent vorsprung hat er
versemmelt 12
beim natürlich tierisch peinlich am tag
nach der wahl haben sie auf mich
gewartet nein nein nein
niemand wartet auch ja der bernd kann er
zusammen mit stanislaw tillich eine
herrenboutique in wuppertal eröffnen
aber vielleicht lags in hannover auch
gar nicht am spitzenkandidaten sondern
anja an biologie die cdu hat ja eine
sehr alte wählerschaft man kann also
sagen sie hat mehr stimmen durch
todesfälle verloren als sie durch
herzfehler hinzugewonnen hat ja gegen
diese sterben musste die politik mal was
machen
gibt's doch gar nicht